hello everyone uh thanks for coming
today we'll be talking about the
multitask and goal condition
reinforcement learning
but before that
a few reminders homework 2 is due today
homework 3 is out it will be a more
lightweight homework so that you can
spend a little bit more time on the
start spending a little bit more time on
the projects
but you should start with it ASAP
especially with setting up all the
dependencies and so on to make sure that
everything works and if it doesn't
please post something on that then we'll
try to help you
um and secondly there is a mid-quarter
survey today and we really appreciate
your feedback so please take the time to
to fill it out we've actually
Incorporated a lot of the changes in the
course because of that survey things
such as switching to pytorch from
tensorflow before adjusting the lecture
topics the homeworks introducing
homework zero and so on so we really
take it seriously it's a please please
uh fill it out and also thank you very
much for the high resolution feedback
that you've been that some of you have
been submitting so far it has been very
useful to us and we we take it really
seriously so thank you
uh one other point is that office hours
can be actually either in person or
virtual and there's been a few
misunderstandings where somebody thought
that it was in person and wasn't so
please check the calendar the calendar
should be able to tell you whether it's
in person or virtual and follow that
So the plan for today's lecture
is first we'll do a little bit of a
recap from last week and we'll finish
the Q learning aspect of reinforcement
learning which we didn't get to talk
about
and then we'll dive into the multi-task
aspect of things so we'll talk about
multitasking mutation learning and
multitask policy gradients
multitask queue learning and data
sharing
and then finally about the goal
condition reinforcement learning which
is also the topic of your of your
homework
all right so let's start with the short
recap
so last week we talked about the anatomy
of a of a reinforcement learning
algorithm and we talked about these
three boxes so there is the box where we
generate the samples when we run the
policy there's a box where we try to
estimate the return of the policy so
what's the sum of the rewards that the
policy is going to get and we have few
different options here we talked about
the Monte Carlo approach where we just
sum the rewards that we achieved
uh we talked a little bit about fitting
a q function or the advantage function
that allows us to do this a little bit
better and we haven't talked about the
model based part which maybe we'll talk
about it next week
or on Wednesday actually
um and then there's the the last box
where we improve the policy and the only
part that we've talked so far about is
the policy gradient approach where we
take a gradient with respect to our
objective and we do gradient Ascent
procedure to improve our policy
and today we'll briefly talk about Q
learning part as well and then next
weeks you will talk about the model
baseboard
and then we introduce this equation
which expresses the gradient with
respect to our objective and this is the
gradient that we use in the policy
gradient approach and if we were to
parse this equation we have the part
that corresponds to the green box which
tells us what's the return of the of the
given policy and this is just the sum of
the rewards starting at the current
action and the current state Up Until
the End these are the the actions and
state that we have actually experienced
then we have this part that corresponds
to The Orange Box where we do multiple
rollouts and we take the average
and then this whole part all together is
how we estimate the gradient with
respect to our objective and then we use
that gradient
um to uh in our policy gradient
procedure uh in gradient in a sense to
actually improve on our policy
all right
cool then we talk a little bit about
multi-step production
about how in standard policy gradient
you would just sum the rewards from now
up until the end of the trajectory we
had this example from from a movie where
what you could do instead is if you had
an option to teleport to the state over
and over again and live multiple Futures
you would be able to estimate the sum of
the rewards much better
um so this is a different way that you
can do this which is the true
expectation of the rewards given that
you start in a the sum of the rewards
even that you start in a given State and
perform a certain action
and then we talked about the the
multi-step prediction where you for
instance play chess and uh you know when
you play chess you don't really have to
wait until the end of the chess chess
match to update your predictions so you
don't have to wait until you finish the
game you can actually start updating it
as soon as you make a move so if you
made a move and you feel like you you
did something wrong you can straight
away update your prediction
and then we talked about how we can
actually use this in the so-called
bootstrap bootstrap estimate and uh the
way we do this is the following we try
to fit the value function
and we do this using supervised
regression so we have our value function
which is the neural network parameters
with some parameters Phi that takes
State as an input and outputs a scalar a
value
and then we need to fit it based on some
kind of targets
so this is our value function the text
States us the input and output is just a
single scalar that tells us how good is
our policy what's the sum of the rewards
from now till the end
so one target we could have is the ideal
Target which is the expected sum of the
true expectation the expected sum of
rewards under our current policy given
that we start in a certain State and we
can approximate it by taking the current
reward plus the value function the next
day
and we can approximate it even even more
whereby rather than taking the True
Value function which we don't have
access to we'll just take our current
estimate of the value function at the
next day
and this is what we refer to as the
bootstrap estimate so this is what
allows us to make these predictions and
update those predictions as soon as we
make a step we don't have to wait until
the end of the trajectory
all right so we talked a little bit
about that and then we introduced two
algorithms we introduced the reinforce
algorithm where we just sample a bunch
of trajectories then apply our policy
gradient formula to estimate the
gradient with respect or objective and
then the gradient ascent
and then at the very end we talked about
the online acrocretic algorithm where we
also do a bunch of different rollouts we
save this kind of Tuple State action
next state and the reward
then we update our value function
according to this bootstrap estimate
that we discussed
in addition we evalu we evaluate the
advantage function
and then we still do the we still
compute the gradient but now it has a
slightly different form and has this
Advantage term here as opposed to the
sum of the rewards but once we do that
we apply the gradient Ascent procedure
and we do this over and over again all
right so this is just the prediction
Parton that's when we finished last time
are there any questions to this part
all right there are no more questions
than
let's talk about how we can actually use
these banks these Q functions value
functions and Advantage functions to
improve the policy so not only to
estimate better what's the sum of the
returns but how we can make the policy
itself better so far the only way we're
making the policy better is by doing
gradient ascent
all right so so far we've been doing
this policy grading approach and this
was our way of computing that gradient
uh or in the actor critic way we will
just replace that with the advantage
so we could make the green box a little
bit better by fitting our value function
here
but now the question is how can we
improve the policy
using some other procedure not
necessarily using gradient ascent
and to think about this just remember
that the advantage function is the
difference between the Q function and
the value function
so the advantage function tells us how
good is an action compared to our
standard policy Pi that we would run
otherwise
so to give you a little bit more of an
intuition of what's going on let's go
back to our exercise that we had last
time so we have this little stick figure
that is dreaming of being a drummer
right and the way that this stick stick
figure will be evaluated in their dream
is that
um they will have to play in a month
this little drumming test and if they
can play they'll get the reward one and
zero otherwise
right and they have these free actions
to choose from they can either chill
they can look they can watch other
drummers perform and try to learn from
that or they can actually practice drums
and they start at some State as the
let's say St equals zero
so at T equals zero so they start at the
very beginning
and the recurrent policy is this policy
where they want to chill all the time so
the the probability of taking action one
is one so they always want to be doing
this
and then we talked about the value
function Q function and the advantage
function in this case
so to test your understanding let's
change this policy a little bit
let's say that uh it's not a stick
figure that wants to chill all the time
but it's a stick figure that just wants
to watch people play drums all the time
so I will say that the pi of A2 given s
is equal one
all right so it just wants to watch
people playing drums so what do you
think is the value function in that case
yep
um
all right yeah let's say something like
0.25
so you would have like a fourth
probability one fourth of a probability
that you will actually play this thing
in a month by just watching people
playing drums all the time okay I think
that's reasonable
what about the Q function of our current
policy Pi so Q Pi of St comma i t
radius here
so Q function tells us what's the
expected sum of rewards given that we
start in a given state so this is the
same state we start at the beginning
given a specific action and then from we
perform this one action and then after
that we continue over our policy pi
so what do you think this would be yep
foreign
so this will be a scalar for a
particular action right so you're saying
that the Q of s t where T equals zero of
a comma a one
A2
okay so if a t is equal to A2 it would
be equal to what sorry
foreign
yeah so it will be higher than what A1
would be but lower than what A3 would be
but it it would it should be exactly the
same as the value function because the
value function was thinking that you're
always your policy is always acting as
if the A2 is the action that you're
performing right so the Q function for
St and A2 should be equal exactly to the
value function so we established that
there is one-fourth of a chance that you
will play this thing at the end of the
month so let's say 0.25 does that make
sense
okay okay and what would it be for A1
then
yes
that's right it will be slightly less
than 0.5 that's right because you
perform this one action where you just
chill for this particular moment but
then after this you'll continue watching
um people play drums and for A3 it will
be a little bit higher all right great
so now what about the advantage function
and let's just consider the advantage
function only for A3
all right so the advantage function
would be of SD comma A3 yes
one positive number yep that's right
that's right so the Q the advantage
function is the difference between the Q
function and the value function so it
kind of tells us how much better is this
action compared to the action that I
would usually take
all right so given that we have all of
these things we have the value function
let's assume that we know it we know the
value function the key function and the
advantage function and we have our
current policy and let's say that our
current policy we go back to chilling
all the time so it's this
so given all of these quantities how can
we improve the policy do you have do you
have any ideas of a simple algorithm
that would allow us to improve the
policy
yes
that's right yeah so just to repeat the
the answer we'll have the positive
Advantage for A2 and A3 so we could
choose among these two and that would if
we do that then we'll have a policy that
is better than the policy we had before
yeah that's great
cool so in particular what we're trying
to do is we have this Advantage function
that tells us how much better is a t
than the average action according to our
policy
and one particular way we can do this we
can take the ARG Max of that right so we
don't necessarily have to choose between
A2 and 3 we can just evaluate all of the
actions and take the arc Max and that
action will definitely be better or the
policy that performs that action will be
no worse than the policy that we
currently perform
and so it will be at least as good as
any action from the policy regardless of
what the policy actually is right so we
don't need to have access to the policy
we just need to have access to the
advantage function
cool so let's say our policy would look
exactly like this so with probability
one we'll be choosing the arc Max of the
advantage function and this will be our
action one second and the probability
zero we'll be doing anything else yes
it seems like the hardest part is
function because
is it common in practice that actually
fits very accurately yeah that's a great
question so the question is uh it seems
that just fitting the value function is
the problem and uh whether it happens in
practice that we can fit it very well
yeah so I think in practice we usually
don't fit it extremely well we also use
algorithms that we'll learn about in I
think
two minutes or so where we are
constantly changing the underlying
policy and the value function is kind of
constantly changing because it's
evaluating value of different different
policies all the time and we don't fit
it perfectly but we fitted well enough
to actually get better and better
policies but you're right fitting the
value function is actually difficult
cool all right so we have this hour we
have this new policy that we know that
should be better than our current one
and uh this is what leads us to an
algorithm called policy iteration so
it's a very simple algorithm where in
the first step we'll be evaluating our
current Advantage function right so the
advantage function of the current policy
and once we have that Advantage function
we'll set the policy to this new policy
and we'll do this over and over again
and the new policy will be equal just
the arc Max of the current Advantage
function
right so very simple algorithm and we
are iterating over the policy
um so that's why it's called policy
iteration
okay cool
and as before the advantage function is
equal to the Q function which is the
reward plus the value function the next
time at the next step minus the value
function of the current step
all right so now
there's two steps that are sort of
magical that get us to the final
algorithm that is actually extremely
useful yes there's a question
right so the question is why even bother
defining Advantage function if it's
defined in terms of Q and V why can't
you just use Q instead
um yeah that's uh so the reason why
people usually use Advantage function is
because it's better normalized right so
you subtract kind of the the think that
that is your Baseline which is the value
function uh however we'll just learn
about it in a second people also use Q
functions instead yeah
so because it's normalized it gives us
another variance and because of that we
can deposit ingredients all better
all right so now let's discuss two steps
that are kind of interesting that would
allow us to get finally to to Q learning
algorithm which is applied all over the
place
all right so we had this policy which
was taking the arc Max of the advantage
function
and when we're doing this Arc Max what
we're actually doing if you remember the
the drummer example we do this argument
just to give us the index of the action
we should be picking right so we take
the arc Max over the advantage and that
just tells us pick A3 right it just
gives us the index
then we know that the advantage function
is equal to Q which is expressed like
this minus the value function
and we know that the arc Max of the
advantage function would be exactly the
same as the arguments of the Q function
right so we can remove the value
function because it's not dependent on
the action and the arguments will be
exactly the same so let's do that it
will be a little bit simpler there's we
get rid of one term so now we can just
say that the Q function is equal to
reward plus the value function at the
next step
cool
so now we can change the The Arc Max
here to be the ARG Max over the Q
function and in the policy iteration
algorithm rather than having the
advantage we'll have the Q function over
here
so we kept everything the same we just
changed advantages to Q
so now here's one track that we that
we'll start with so because we are using
this Arc Max just to give us the index
and then as soon as we have that index
we'll have to evaluate it in the next
step again
right so we kind of have this new policy
but this policy is only useful as far as
evaluating the the Q function of that
new policy we don't actually use the
policy itself we just use the value of
that policy in the next step
so the idea is let's skip the policy
entirely let's kind of get rid of the
middleman and just compute the values
directly
so the ARG Max of our Q was the policy
and the value of that new policy would
be actually the max of the queue right
so the argument was kind of giving us
the index of the action but the max of
the queue is giving us the value of that
new policy which was the The Arc Max
right this is a little bit of a a little
bit of a trick but it's actually
extremely useful
all right so this approximates the new
value
right and that leads us to a value
iteration algorithm which is kind of the
a similar version to policy iteration
but now we'll be iterating on the value
itself so this is how it works we set
the queue to be equal to the reward plus
the value of the next step so this is
what the Q Q function is
but then they will update the value
function to be the max of the queue all
right so this is kind of like in the
previous step here we were updating the
policy here we are updating the value of
the new policy so because the new policy
will be the arc Max of the queue we can
just say that the value of that new
policy that is the r Max of the queue is
just the max of the queue
and we do this over and over again and
we are iterating on the value and this
is the value iteration
cool so that means that in the green box
we have this queue now
and to improve the policy we are just
setting the values equal to the max of
our actions of the queue
so now the question is we have this
algorithm
right
and now we can we have to implement it
right like we have to have some neural
networks that actually
um learn something and try to fit either
the value function or the Q function
so this is called value iteration so
let's maybe start with value function
all right we'll try to have a neural net
that represents a value function so it
takes a status input and outputs a
scalar which is the expected sum of
Rewards
and uh let's see if we can do that all
right so
let's write it on the board here
so let's see our value function
V of s parameters with some parameters
pi
would be equal
to the max
over actions
of the queue but we don't have a neural
network that represents the queue so
let's Express Q in terms of the V
and we have that in the in the line in
the in Step number one so this would be
the max of r
s comma a
Plus
this counted expectation of the value at
the next state
all right and this expectation is with
respect to P of S Prime given s comma I
all right
so this would be our Target
for the for the value function
right
and uh we'll be trying to minimize the
difference between the two and we'll
optimize the neural network to do that
there's a question yep
that's a great point so the question was
uh don't you need to know the transition
Dynamics because you're taking the
expectation and you need to know what
the next state is yes that's true so
there's this problem of this equation
which is if we were actually trying to
implement this we have the value
function that takes a state as input so
we have state that is available to us
and then we have to take the max over
all the actions that are possible
right so we can try different actions
so we would need to know the reward
function let's say that we know that for
a specific State we know given a
specific action what the reward function
is but then we would need to know what
would be the next state that I would end
up in given that action so that we can
compute the value function of that next
state
right but to know this we will be
testing different actions right because
we'll need to take the max of our
actions so to know this we would need to
know what would be the different states
that we would end up in given those
different actions right we would have to
you know let's say we have 10 different
actions to choose from for each one of
these actions you would need to know
what the next state is so that you can
input this to your value function to
your neural net so you need to know the
transition Dynamics which was which was
the question
yep
so the question is can you just randomly
sample because you haven't expected
value
[Music]
right but to sample from this
distribution you don't actually have
access to all the different actions that
you could perform you only have access
to the actions that you did perform
yeah all right okay so in that case you
would need to kind of know had I
performed that other action that I've
never actually tried what state would I
end up in and you don't have access to
that you don't know what what the future
would be
all right so the value function doesn't
quite work
and that's what leads us to the final
algorithm Q learning
so
again we have the value iteration
algorithm but now instead of fitting the
value function
let's just fit the queue function
instead
right so we keep everything exactly the
same but now instead of learning the
value function we'll be learning the Q
function
so let's do that
second okay cool cool so now our targets
will will be trying to fit a q function
parameters with some parameters as comma
a
and this would be equal to
the reward
of s comma a
Plus
the expected next value and the next
value is the max of the queue right so
the Max over actions this is a different
action this is not this action that is
the input this is let's call it a prime
um of the Q at S Prime comma a prime
all right and this is this is the Q
function that is parameterized with the
same parameters
right so it's exact same thing now we're
fitting the Q function instead of the
value function yes
how are we getting the S Prime yeah
that's a that's a great question so
let's let's think about this equation
first and then we'll get how we how we
get the S Prime
so now we the input Tower Q function is
State and action all right so now our Q
function looks a little bit different
right our Q function is now uh has two
inputs states in the action and then
outputs the value
right so this is expressed here and
given state of an action we have access
to a reward function so we can compute
the reward
and now we have this Max term again but
now it's a little bit different
so the max is taking the max over all
the actions
of the Q function of the next state
right but now let's ignore the next
state for a second but in terms of the
actions we can actually do this right
our Q function is dependent on both
state and action so we can try we can
plug in all kinds of different actions
that we haven't taken and compute the
max
right we don't have to simulate now
what's going to happen next
we can just plug in the actions because
this is part of the input of our
function and just try it out and see
what happens
now how do we get the next state so the
way we would do this is actually similar
to how we did what we did in the active
credit case we would just be saving so
this this next state here this is just
the function
of the current state and the action
right it's independent of the policy or
of the Q function or anything like this
so what we'll be saving as we as we run
the policy in the world will be saving
so-called SARS tuples so we'll be saving
State action reward that we got and the
next state that we observe
and then from that we'll be
approximating this expectations from the
states that we have actually seen
so we can just record as we as we run
the policy we'll be recording these four
values so that we have access to S Prime
that we've actually experienced and here
we will be plugging that as Prime that
we've seen
foreign
[Music]
right cool so this is what gets us to Q
learning doesn't require simulation of
actions
and we can do this
so a quick recap a few definitions that
we introduced here we have the value
function that tells us the total rewards
starting from State and then following
our policy
so in other words in that answers the
question how good is the is the state
then we have the Q function which is the
teller reward starting from s taking a
single action and then following the
policy
which answers the question how good is
the is the given State action pair
and then for this optimal policy
we just introduced this this equation
right here
we have this this dependency that says
the Q function the optimal Q function
which will be depict of star so this is
now the optimal policy is pi star is
equal to this expectation and this is
the reward that we got for the given
state in action so this expectation is
actually unnecessary for the reward plus
the max over actions of the Q of the
next action
and this is what we refer to as the
Belmont equation or the Bellman
optimality equation and this is one of
the most important equations in
reinforcement learning
all right so let's go back to our
drumming example
so we talked about the value function
the Q function
what is the Q function of the optimal
policy so our Q star so this is not Q Pi
which is the current policy and the
current policy is you know the stick
figure wants to chill all the time
what's the Q function of the optimal
policy Pi star so what's Q star
any ideas
yes
because
because
that's right yeah so just to repeat this
for everyone
um a for A3 it would be one that means
that you're practicing all the time
including the current time step for A2
it would be a little bit less than one
you just watch for a second and then you
practice all the time
and for A1 it will be a little bit less
so you take a an hour off let's say you
do chill and then you practice for the
rest of the month
cool
and what would be the value function the
V Star of s0
please just don't be shy raise your hand
ideas or just shout out the answer
yes
that's right it could be one because the
optimal action would be A3 yeah so this
takes uh this assumes that you're acting
optimally straight away
cool
all right so we introduced this fitted
queue iteration algorithm which works
like this we have a few hyper parameters
so first we collect the the data set
using some policy and we collect the
source to put so State action next state
and the reward
and let's say we have a data data size
and data set size n and there's some
collection policy that we collect the
data with
then we set our targets for the queue
function according to the Belmont
equation that we just introduced
and then we minimize the distance
between the Q function and the targets
and our Q function is this is this
neural net that takes States in action
as an input and outputs a single scalar
value
so we do this over as gradient steps
right we can do this a few times
and then we do this we we can iterate in
terms of updating the targets K times
right so we can apply a few gradient
steps and then we would update the
targets because now our Q function has
changed so this Max term will be
changing and it's an iterative procedure
so we're getting kind of we're
approximating Q star better and better
over time
and then we go back to collecting the
data set
and as a result we can get the policy by
just taking the arc Max of the queue
there's a question
[Music]
yeah that's a great question so the
question is do we have to do in step two
a bunch of forward passes uh one pass
per a prime
um uh technically yes but you can batch
them together
yep
uh in terms of stuff I think you should
do that fine but instead of my course
but it's not foreign
so we're saying that this queue over
here should be a should have a different
parameters than the Q over here yeah
that's like uh right yeah yeah so this
is one of the implementation
um things that people introduced to make
this procedure much more stable and they
introduce a Target Network here because
this network is constantly changing
we're constantly applying gradient steps
to it and it causes some instability in
learning so instead what people do is
they copy the values of this network
once and then use that Target network
with copied values here
and then apply the the gradient steps to
this network that's constantly being
updated and every now and then they
would update the target Network to the
network that they've been using yeah
that's a that's the implementation trick
that people use that's right
all right so a few important notes we
can reuse data from previous policies
right so here we are just using some
policy it's not an on policy algorithm
we don't have to be rolling out from the
current policy this is any policy
there's a question uh it's not a good
question
yeah that's a great question and we'll
answer this in one minute oh yeah
correct question though the question was
uh how would you do it in the continuing
how would you take that Max in a
continuous case and can you batch the
actions then
um all right so
um we can reuse data from previous
policies it's an alph policy algorithm
we don't have to be running the policy
that we're currently learning it could
be we could be running any policy
um in practice what people do is they
push these Source supposed to replay
buffers and then they have one big
replay buffer with all the data and they
just sample from that buffer to do the
updates
and importantly this is not a gradient
that's an algorithm right so even though
we are trying to fit the queue function
to the targets and this is where we
apply gradient descent
the the algorithm how we learn better
and better policies
um is a recursive iterative algorithm uh
which uses dynamic programming all right
so here we are constantly updating our Q
function according to this formula and
this doesn't require gradient descent we
use gradient descent to just fit the Q
function to the current Target
all right so now a quick example
and this is the example of continuous
actions so we'll try to apply Q learning
to robotics
so this is our algorithm so now the
question is how do we take that Max of
our actions where robots move in
continuous space right like they their
actions are continuous they need to get
to a certain pose for instance so we can
just enumerate all the actions this is a
continuous action
so one way we can take that that Max
here is by running a simple optimization
algorithm and there is this gradient
free optimization algorithm called
cross-entropy method or cem and the way
it works is actually really simple
you would start with a normal
distribution
all right and then you would sample a
bunch of actions from the normal
distributions normal distribution and
then score each one of them right so I
would start with let's say 20 actions I
sample all of them and then I query my Q
function what's the value of each one of
those actions right and some of them
will have higher values some of them
will have lower values so the higher
values here are in Gray
and then I can do another iteration of
CM where I would now fit a gaussian to
my Elites to the best actions that I the
actions that achieve the highest score
and then perform this procedure again
yeah
so this is a type of an evolutionary
algorithm or a gradient free
optimization method
um you can use any other optimization
method
um to just find the max of a of a
function this is just a very simple
thing that was actually applied to the
robots
cool all right so let's do all of this
so this is the work called QT opt done
by Dimitri Kalashnikov at all at Google
brain
and the way it works is the following we
store data from all the past experiments
then we have a bunch of buffers the off
policy buffer where we put all the data
in as well as the on policy buffer where
we currently collect the experience
we have our queue Network which is
parameterized by some parameters faded
and then we have this separate process
this is running at Large Scale these are
parallel so we have the separate process
that's called the Bellman updater which
is just Computing the target values for
the current Q function all right so all
it does is just computes the reward plus
the max of the next queue
and this uses the CM optimization to get
that Max
and then once it does that it would push
these targets to a buffer as well and
then from this buffer we'll have a set
of training jobs that are just doing
gradient descent that are just trying to
fit the queue function to that Q Target
and update the parameters of the neural
net this is heavily parameterized and
running on thousands of machines
cool so this was applied to grasping and
the the mdp definition for grasping was
the following
so the state was the the image captured
by the camera that was here over the
shoulder camera and this is what the
image looked like
the action was four degrees of freedom
post change in the Cartesian space so it
was controlled it was the top top down
grasp and it was controlling the
position as well as the yaw the
orientation here
plus the gripper control so it could
also tell whether the gripper should
close or open
and the reward was binary so it would
just say at the very end of the
trajectory if you grasp something
successfully you get reward one zero
otherwise that's it
and we actually implemented an automatic
success detection mechanism for this
which was very simple so at the end of
the trajectory the robot is either
holding something in its hand or it's
not so what we will do is we will take
an image when it's holding or at the end
of the episode and then we'll open the
gripper and take another image now if
you're holding something then the
difference between these two images
would be non-zero right because you just
dropped something into the bin if you
didn't hold anything
the difference would be easier so very
simple automatic success detection
mechanism
right so in terms of the results uh we
used seven robots to collect over 580
000 grasps
and it was evaluated on previously
unseen objects so we'll just like drop a
whole bunch of different objects into
the bins let the robots run them run
with them and practice grasping
um and then we would evaluate it on
objects that the robots never seen
before
and at success rate was really high it
was 96 96 success rate
and that was actually really surprising
to us that we could get to a number this
High because grasping is not a new
problem people have been working on
grasping for
50 years or so and this is I think the
first time where we were able to see
that this problem can be actually solved
and we can grasp objects that the robots
never seen before
and here are some examples of strategies
that the robots learned
so here you can see that this grasping
is kind of full of contact and it's
interacting with the environment which
is very difficult to prescribe or to
engineer upfront so here you know it's
trying to simulate the object that's
moving the other objects apart and so on
to grasp it
here there is an example of a reactive
Behavior where it's trying to grasp this
tennis ball
and I think in a second you will see an
example where there's a mean
experimenter and it's moving the tennis
ball away and the robot understands that
you know the ball is not there anymore
and it follows it and gets to a state
that has high Q value
or here's one more case where it's a
very flat object that is really
difficult to grasp and the robot learn
how to retry and kind of fully
understand what it means to grasp
something and it tries it a few times
until until it gets it right
so it kind of understands that some
actions are some Q values for some of
those states are not as high as they
should be so it runs this Max to find
the better action
until the the moment where it actually
grasps it and then succeeds
all right so to summarize Q learning
uh in terms of Pros we have uh this is a
More Sample efficient than on policy
methods
we can incorporate off policy data
including a fully offline setting that
we'll discuss in in I think two weeks
and we can update the policy even
without seeing the reward kind of like
in the chess match that we discussed
before as soon as you make the next
production you can update the policy
and it's relatively easy to parallelize
how we just saw in in QT up case and in
terms of the cons there's lots of tricks
to make it work including Target
networks and other things
and potentially it could be harder to
learn than just the policy itself
because you need to model kind of the
landscape of all of the actions
all right any questions yes
um
yeah great question so the the question
was how do you encode the fact that you
wanted to grasp a tennis ball
um this was just an accident so we
didn't encode the thing anyway so this
is not an instance grasping system it
just grasps anything that it sees yep
right so if you let it run for a little
longer it would eventually pick all of
them one by one
to
download
disease
right yeah so the question was why
didn't we use some other method like uh
ddpg that is fairly popular that is
another way of getting the max of the Q
function in a continuous case
um the main reason is because it was
much simpler to do it this way and we
didn't want to have a separate actor and
there's actually a lot of instabilities
that come with using an actor critic
method like this so we just wanted to
make it simple easy to paralyze and it
was good enough
all right cool
all right so that's the end of the recap
and Q learning let's dive into the the
multitask stuff the the exciting part
about imitation and policy gradients
so we talked a little bit about
imitation learning before
um we had this example where we had
human drivers collect some images and
the actions that they were performing
and uh we would put them in in the big
training data set and then supervised
learning on it doing imitation learning
so now the question is how do we do this
with multiple tasks
right
so first question as well how do we
optimize multi multitasking mutation
learning setting and the answer is
really simple
and that's this is the reminder from
lecture two the Chelsea that Chelsea
gave we just use the vanilla multitask
objective where we minimize the loss
across different tasks right so we can
have some kind of way of specifying
which task it does and then we can
compute the loss for each one of the
tasks and take the sum of those and
minimize that
so it's exactly the same as supervised
learning
so we can use same architecture
stratified sampling everything that
you've learned about soft soft or hard
weight sharing and so on very simple
right so the other question is how do
you specify a task right so let's say
you're trying to teach a robot something
you need to specify multiple tasks using
imitation learning you collect
demonstrations for each one of them how
would you specify the task
any ideas
how would you communicate to a robot
what task you wanted to do levels
that's right but you have to specify the
task to robot somehow so what would you
use for that
how would you describe the task
yes
um as a as a by classifying a reward
function
right so different reward function the
different tests would have different
reward functions but still you would
have a neural network that would need to
be conditioned on a task right and this
conditioning needs to be specified
somehow right like you need to tell the
robot or you need to explain what kind
of task you want it to do it would have
different rewards for all of these for
all of these tasks but how would the
robot know which tasks to perform
yes
yeah you can use a one hot Vector right
so it would be just you know one heart
telling you which task you're in
yeah right yeah you can use demos so you
would perform a demonstration and that
would be some kind of embedding of this
demonstration will be the description of
a task you can specify it by natural
language you can specify it by video by
a goal image all kinds of different
things and these different things have
different trade-offs so there's this one
work that was published at Coral by Eric
Jenga doll I called BCC
and the way it works is the following so
they collected a big data set of of
demonstrations
which resulted in this diverse multitask
data set so they're doing many different
tasks
and then they were actually conditioning
the policy on two different things on
the video it's a human video of
performing a task and a natural language
description as well
and then they would based on this they
would test how well does it generalize
to a task that it's never seen before
right so they'll generalize some tasks
that have that haven't been seen which
is kind of a novel thing to do
their architecture looks like this this
is the state so they take the the image
from the camera then they random crop it
down sample it so they have the smaller
image
which goes through a pre-trained
resonant Network and then does a few
operations and eventually ends up in
outputs the action that the robot should
do
and then they have this way of encoding
the task and they have two different
ways here so they can either take the
human video so they record human videos
that are paired to the to the tasks that
the robot is trying to do
they pass it for a video encoder and
this ends up being and this ends up in
some kind of embedding vector
in some latent space
and they also have a language natural
language description of the task which
goes through a language encoder in this
case I believe this was a pre-trained
language model
which ends up in some space in this in
this embedding space and then they use
film conditioning to condition this
resnet on the task that I want to do
in terms of the last two years so they
take the they do the minimum negative
log likelihood so they're minimizing
this overall the tasks that we just
discussed and they have the behavioral
cloning loss where z i here depicts the
embedding of the task you're in
and then in addition to this for this to
work well they added one more loss which
is the language regression loss so
they're trying to minimize the distance
between the video encoder and the
language encoder for a specific for a
specific task and this makes the video
encoder a little bit better
all right so in terms of the results
here are some of the tasks that head out
held out tasks that they that they've
been evaluating it on and you can see
that you know some of them kind of
worked some of them work fairly well
like 82 or so some of them don't work at
all like some of the language
descriptions that you see here like
Place banana in a ceramic cup
and uh overall the held out task success
is just 32 percent but keep in mind that
this is the first time where we're
actually trying to evaluate something
and tests that you've never seen before
so they trained on a completely
different set of tasks so this here we
are testing generalization to new tasks
so there is non-zero success for 20 of
the 28 tasks and the average was the
average success of these held up tax was
32 and here are some examples of what
this actually does so here is a test
that it's never seen before for instance
push purple ball across the table
and you can see that it that it does
that we hear another test that it's
never been seen before place a bottle in
a tray
right so in this case they use natural
language as the task specification and
this allows them to do some zero shot
um generalization where they can specify
a different text command and the robot
does that
all right cool so now we also talk about
reinforcement learning and we talk a
little bit about what is a task in
reinforcement learning and we talked
about this definition the the mdp where
we have the state space the action space
the initial State distribution the
Dynamics and the reward
so an alternative view that uh was
already said in the class was to add the
task identifier as part of the state so
we can just say that our original state
was this S Bar
and then we'll add our task description
zi you know either natural language or
something else and the the stuple would
be our new state so now our new state
also encompasses what task you're trying
to do
and if we take that view
then we can just say that this
multitasker reinforcement learning
problem is just another mdp right so in
that case the mdp would be the the state
space is equal to the union of all the
state spaces of all the tasks the action
space is the union of all the action
spaces the initial State distribution is
the mixture and then it has some
Dynamics and the reward function
so it can be cast as a standard MDB
all right we also talked about the goal
of reinforcement learning in the
previous lecture this was the single
task case the multitask case is very
similar so it's the same as before
except now we have this task identifier
that tells us which task we're in
an example of this would be one hot task
ID or a language description or a
desired goal image now if we use the or
the gold state
if we use the the desired gold state
then our zi our description of a task
would be equal to some State as G right
so it will be in the same the same
dimensionality in the same space as the
states themselves
and this is actually a really important
case that we'll spend a little bit more
time on
and this is what we'll be referring to
as single condition reinforcement
learning all right so we're conditioning
on the goal that we actually want to see
in the world
if we want to achieve
so what is the reward in this case
it could be the same as before or for
gold condition RL the reward could be
just the distance or the negative
distance between our current state and
the state that we want to get to
right so it will be just the negative
distance between the two
some examples of that would be the
euclidean distance or a sparse reward so
if the two states are exactly the same
you get reward otherwise you don't
or something else
so this is the gold conditioner rail
case the multitask oral case fairly
simple
all right
um yeah so in terms of the conditioning
we can you know we already discussed two
different ways of of specifying the task
to uh to an agent and it turns out that
it actually matters how you specified
and it's not that it's not just that it
matters because you know it's maybe more
convenient to talk to a robot than
specifying a one hot Vector to a robot
but it actually also helps with learning
so to discuss this we'll look at this
Benchmark called meta World which
consists of 50 different tasks 50
different manipulation tasks that have
the same robot the same state space and
action space but they do slightly
different things right simple
manipulation tests that you see here
and it turns out that when we evaluate
whole bunch of different multi-task
versions of popular
um of popular multitasker enforcement
learning algorithms they don't work that
well so even though you can solve each
one of those tasks separately quite well
if you put them all together and you try
to learn them all together it doesn't
work that well so the success rate is at
like 50 or so
so there's this idea introduced by
sudhani at all called care where instead
of specifying tasks as one hot vectors
which is what was done here before
they would introduce so-called metadata
metadata right here
so the metadata would be a short
language description telling you what
the task actually is so for instance it
would say you know
insert the peg inside the hole or
something like this
now they would use that metadata with a
with they would pass it through a
pre-trained language model and then have
another
feed forward neural net
to get some kind of context
right and they'll take this context
vector and then separately they would
have the the state that has to pass
through K different encoders that are
being trained
and then they would look at the output
of all of these encoders and then do
attention overdose according to the
context that they got from the metadata
from the pre-trained language model so
kind of the language model tells you
what part of the context or which which
encoders you should be paying attention
to
then they pass it through an MLP so a
feed for neural net and then they
combine these two and then this is the
representation of the task and then they
run it through the policy algorithm
so it's kind of it's a different way of
conditioning right so they're still
running the same multitask reinforcement
learning but now the task is specified
by the metadata and there is some
um there's some kind of trickery as to
how this is being processed but the
important part is that there is some
language description that tells you the
connection between different tasks
and it turns out that it works a little
bit better and they actually showed a
few a few different ablations in their
paper showing how this works and why
that is
but one particular one that I found
interesting is right here so they tested
on 10 tasks and these are the
descriptions of the tasks
and here they show this uh this
confusion Matrix showing you the
similarities between the different tasks
so in in here the this this Matrix right
here B this is the cosine similarity
between the pre-trained language
embeddings of those tasks so we can see
that test number nine and ten seem to be
very similar and this has something to
do with pushing a window so the
pre-frame language model puts them kind
of close together
C is the case with their six encoders so
if they're a care model and they can see
that there is actually a lot of
similarities between the different
groups of tasks so not only nine and ten
are similar but it looks like four five
and six are fairly similar right so four
five and six is open a door with a
revolving joint open a drawer push and
close the drawer so it seems like the
Motions that that you have to perform to
perform these tasks and also the way
that they're described share a lot of
similarities so they can be mapped kind
of together and metadata helps with that
and then they also show
um what what what this Matrix looks like
if there is if they don't use metadata
at all so there's no similarities
between the tasks
so it seems that the right context not
only can help us interact with the robot
but we can actually provide interesting
context for the training algorithm
itself right it shows certain
similarities between the tasks we
describe tasks in certain way because
you know there are similarities how we
perceive the world right like if you
push something or pick something or pull
something you know the reason why these
words are sort of seems similar is
because these correspond to similar
activities and the model can actually
take advantage of that
all right I'm gonna skip some of this
because we're running out of time
um but I also wanted to tell you a
little bit about the difficulties of
multitask reinforcement learning
so when we look at meta world for the
first time we saw that if we train all
the tasks independently so each task is
by itself from one of those 50 tasks it
actually works much better than if we
train them all together using one hot
conditioning or even using any other
conditioning
so we tried the different hypotheses we
tried to making the network much bigger
collecting much more data trying all
kinds of different things but none of
them really seem to help
so then we looked at one more thing we
looked at the gradient cosine
similarities between different tasks so
in particular we took the task zero and
task one and just plot over the number
of gradient steps what's the gradient
causing similarity so the gradients for
different tasks how do they relate to
each other
and it turned out that it's all over the
place so sometimes it's positive so that
means that they're aligned sometimes
they're perpendicular which means the
cosine is zero and sometimes they're
negative so one task is pulling in One
Direction the other task is pulling in
another Direction which kind of seems to
be a problem
so then we came up with this very simple
algorithm which says if two gradients
conflict then let's project each onto
the normal plane of the other and if
they don't conflict we don't do anything
so it's a very simple algorithm that
looks at the gradient vectors for two
different tasks and if they're
conflicting so if this angle here is
more than 90 degrees it would project
one of the gradients onto the normal
plane of the other and the same with the
other one and if they're non-conflicting
we won't do anything
right
so we apply this so first thing we
started seeing is that we call this
algorithm and PC grad and this was uh
um this is the work led by Kevin you
and the first thing we start to see is
obviously because by of the definition
of this algorithm uh we don't have
conflicting gradients anymore right like
every every time the gradient is
conflicting we'll project it and it's
not conflicting anymore so now the plot
looks like the one in green
but then in addition what we started
seeing is that the performance now with
the PC grad in purple is actually much
much better than what we've seen before
so not only it's better than the the
things that we've seen before when we
train them jointly but it's also better
than if we train the tasks independently
right and that seems to indicate that
there is actually quite a lot of
structure that you can take advantage of
in the in the meta World tasks which is
not that surprising these are similar
manipulation tasks and by fiddling a
little bit with the optimization you
might be able to extract those
advantages and and actually see that
and here I think we're just scratching
the surface of the problems that you see
when optimizing for multiple tasks and
so on and it shows that even very simple
algorithms can actually improve the
performance quite significantly
all right so to summarize the
multitasker well algorithm we change a
policy to now include also the task
information CI
we can do the same with the Q function
the queue function can now also
incorporate the task information CI
and it's analogous to multitask
supervised learning so we can use the
same things again stratified sampling
soft heart weight sharing Etc
and if it's a still Mark of if it's
still a mark of decision process well
why can't we just apply standard erl
algorithms and so far we've talked about
more or less standard RL algorithms
maybe with the exception of PC gran
and the answer is yeah you can do that
and it actually works fairly well
but we can often do much better than
this and that's what we'll discuss next
and
to think about this what do you think we
could do what is different about
reinforcement learning
um in contrast to supervised learning
what what are the other aspects that we
can control that could help us here
any ideas
yes
we can choose where we want to explore
that's right yeah exactly so the data
distribution is controlled by the agent
itself
so the question that we'll try to answer
next is can we share the data in
addition to sharing the ways and how
should we share the data or how should
we explore so that
um we can take more advantage of the
multitasker algorithms
all right so this is where we talk about
multitasker learning are there any
questions at this point
all right cool
so to explain this data sharing problem
let's consider the following example
let's say we are playing hockey and we
want to learn two different tasks
one task is passing
and task number two is shooting goals or
scoring goals I guess
and let's say you collected some
experience where you were trying to make
a good pass
but um oh sorry you're trying to shoot
at the goal but accidentally you
performed a good pass right so it's not
what you intended but it just it just
happened this way
so what can you do in this case in the
reinforcement learning setup
well you can store the experience as
normal so you can store that experience
of you performing a path but you're
trying to shoot a goal as just an
example of trying to shoot a goal right
the the example of task one or sorry
task two
but in addition to this you can also
relabel that experience with task 2 ID
right so just you can pretend that
you're trying to shoot a goal from the
very beginning
this is sorry I messed it up a little
bit so we label the experience with Task
1 ID
um and the reward and store that as well
right so you're trying to shoot a goal
and you ended up passing so you can
store this as an example of shooting a
goal but you can also store it as an
example of passing
so you can kind of double the size of
the data set now
and this is what we're referring to as
hindsight relabeling or hindsight
experience replay or in short hair
cool so the way the the algorithm would
work with this and this is actually
quite important and this will be um
partly this is also the topic of
homework three
it it would work as following we would
collect the data using some kind of
policy as we do in reinforcement
learning and this would result in some
State sequence some action sequence and
some description for of a task so we're
trying to perform task I
and we have the reward associated with
that task
then we'll store that data in a replay
buffer as we usually do
and then we would in addition perform
this hindsight relabeling procedure
so relabel the experience that we just
collected but we'll relabel it for a
different task for a task TJ
all right so it's the J task not the I
task that we originally collected the
data for
so now that that data would look like
this it would still be the same sequence
of actions same sequence of States but
now rather than saying that this was Z I
will just say this was ZJ right like I
was actually trying to pass
and then we would also have to relabel
the reward as the reward that is the
reward for task J
right so we have to now score it
according to did you pass or did you not
pass
and then we can start to relabel the
relabel data in the replay buffer as
well
and then updated policy and do this over
and over again there's a question yeah
yeah that's a great question so the
question is um when when do we do this
when do we do this relabeling do we do
it only when we perform something useful
for this other task or not yeah and this
is actually one of the one of the big
questions in reinforcement learning as
to how to do it so let's consider a few
options what what task which task should
you choose so one idea would be to
choose it randomly right just like
relabel it to any other task but the
idea that you had was well we maybe we
should relabel it to tasks or tasks in
which trajectory gets high reward right
so only if you actually pass to someone
you should relabel it as passing if you
if it resulted in something completely
random then you shouldn't relabel this
as passing
and there are different options here and
these different options actually have
really big influence on the final
results
there's other options here as well and
here are some papers that talk about
different ways how you can relabel that
and these either use certain heuristics
or look at offline cases or offline
reinforcement learning cases and so on
but usually I think they correspond to
something that you describe which is
relabel to tasks that have a high chance
of achieving a reward or two tasks that
seem like something that you could have
done had you tried that task
yes there's a question in this case
yes so we assume that they have the same
Dynamics that's that's a great point
so when can we apply relabeling so
reward function needs to be known
because
um you know we need to evaluate now the
the state for for a different task
Dynamics needs to be you need to be
consistent as you as you said across
call some tasks and then we also need to
be using an off policy algorithm there
is actually a way to use on policy
algorithms with that as well but of
course the algorithms works much better
all right so one more example as to why
off or on policy how do they compare
here
so let's look at another example so
let's say one task is to close the
drawer and the other task is to open a
drawer right these are the two tasks
so you get a high reward when the doors
are when the drawers are closed in the
other case you get the highest reward
when the drawer is fully open
so now the question is can we use
episodes from their opening tasks for
drawing closing tasks but more
importantly how does that answer change
for Q learning versus policy gradient
and for the purpose of this exercise
let's assume that if you're trying to
close a drawer you will not accidentally
open it or if you're trying to open a
drawer you will not accidentally close
it right so these tests are kind of
completely orthogonal you can't succeed
at a task by trying the other task
so what do you think can you can you use
the episodes from one task for the other
um and how does the sensor change for Q
learning and policy grading any any
ideas
yes
sorry say that again
right right so the answer was that uh
well it's a binary surface so you either
your the drawers either open or closed
so you can always read a little bit as
one of the other so let's say that the
drawer can be also half open and in
which case you don't get rewards for
either of them
right so like the drawers like this
um you don't get rewards you didn't you
didn't open it you didn't close it
either yes
right yeah so it's partly with the right
answer so yeah just to repeat the answer
you're saying that when we're trying to
when we look at the data that we
collected by trying to close the drawer
the rewards for opening the drawer for
the data will be zero
and then you said that because of that Q
learning wouldn't work
now the answer is actually so this is
the really good point that when you try
to close the drawer that's what I was
trying to get to you want to open it so
the rewards for that will be zero
but now the answer would change for
policy grading versus skill learning and
let's take a look again at the policy
gradient gradient estimation
and this here the gradient is dependent
on the rewards that you actually achieve
so if the rewards are zero for the when
you're trying to close the drawer data
set and you're relabel it to opening the
drawers this rewards are zero then this
gradient will be zero right so with
policy gradients you can't really use
the negative examples of other tasks for
your current tasks
for Q learning however you can use that
secure learning remember the chest
example you can actually take into
account any interaction and you can use
that interaction to update your your Q
function
yes
if the rewards were plus one and minus
one what would that how would that
change things
yeah so I think
what would happen in practice in that
case is that you would try to normalize
the rewards and subtract the Baseline
this is how people actually Implement
implement this in practice so that the
rewards are between zero and one so then
you it would still result in the same in
the same thing
all right cool so one more example that
I wanted to show you which is the
extension of QT opt but applied to
multiple tasks
so again we use a bunch of robots to
collect data for a whole bunch of
different manipulation tasks and now we
collect an episode we label it using a
success detector as success or failure
and then we we call this process
impersonation that is the same as
hindsight labeling we can use that
episode we'll see it again in a second
we can use this episode as successes or
failures for other tasks and replicate
it and use it for those other tasks and
then we sample from all of those tasks
and we do the QT Ops training just on
multiple tasks to to do this
now we can train a set of manipulation
tasks that are relatively simple
manipulation tests such as picking
stacking picking specific objects
pushing all kinds of different things
and first thing we see is that we get 80
average improvement over baselines
across all the tasks and in particular
we get 4X Improvement of our single test
so if we take the exact same data set
and try to train a single task train
multiple tasks seems to be much much
better so it looks like the algorithm is
able to kind of take advantage of the
structure that they discovered among
these different tasks
in addition to this we see very large
improvements for tasks with very little
data so the less data there is the more
kind of the structure that you discover
from learning all of them at the same
time seems to help
and then lastly we can also use a
pre-trained network that we pre-train on
a bunch of different tasks and fine-tune
it to a new tasks relatively quickly so
we can collect data for this new task in
just one day and Achieve 92 percent
success for the tasks that we've never
seen before but we use this neural
network that we train here as a
pre-training and this is the task that
we traded on which is this covering the
block with a tablet
all right so we talked a little bit
about data sharing and multitask queue
learning are there any questions at this
point
right so it would benefit in the Q
learning case so just repeat the
question in the drawer case wouldn't any
episode actually benefit either you open
the drawer opening a door closing it
would benefit it as long as you use
something like Q learning if the rewards
for the tasks that you're re-labeling it
to are zero then they don't contribute
to the policy grading case data
I think
right right
yeah that's a that's a great point so
yeah the question was in the Q learning
case
um if you only had data from one of the
tasks like closing the drawer and you've
never seen opening the drawer succeed
you don't have the thinner data set
skill learning still wouldn't help you
because you wouldn't be able to discover
that uh so you you can use it to augment
the data but not necessarily to kind of
generate the data fully
it shouldn't hurt
yeah I think it shouldn't hurt I think
that's right and probably when you when
the door drawer is completely closed and
you only have the opening data that
you're only trying to open it and the
reward function for the for the very
initial state will be high and therefore
this is an example of driving opponent
will probably store
all right so there's one last point that
I wanted to get to which is actually the
most important
so this is the goal condition
reinforcement learning so we talked
about this goal condition RL and how we
use the states as the description of a
task and this is actually the topic of
homework 3.
so how would it work with hindsight
relabeling
so again we have our data that we stored
we State the we store the state's
actions and now the task description is
the actually gold state that we want to
get to SG
so we do it using some policy we store
the data in the replay buffer and now we
can perform hindsight pre-labeling
so now we can relabel the experience
that we just collected but we can
relabel it using the last state that we
achieved as the goal that we wanted to
get to right so now any state in the
trajectory is a potential task
description so what we can say is that
you know you perform some kind of
trajectory random trajectory but you can
always say that the last state in the
trajectory is a goal that you wanted to
achieve and now you have a successful
example of you trying to achieve that
goal
right
so we can do this so now we take the
last state that we achieved and we use
that as our SG right this is our this is
our task that we wanted to
where the reward is the distance between
the the current state and the final
state that we got
so it's kind of like you know every time
we're doing something we're pretending
that this is what we wanted to do
all right then we store that experience
in the in the replay buffer and update
the policy using
um using the buffer and we iterate over
this now can you think of any other
relabeling strategies actually we're
running out of time so let me just tell
you
um in terms of other relabeling
strategies we can also use any other
state in the trajectory right we don't
have to only look at the final State we
can look at any of the states that we've
encountered and just say that this was
the goal and now this sub trajectory is
the is the trajectory that I wanted to
get to
the result of this is that it helps with
exploration
and this was actually shown in this
original hindsight experience replay
paper in Europe's in 2017. where we have
gold condition around assimilated robot
manipulation domain where we're trying
these three different tasks pushing
sliding and picking place
and we can see that when we apply hair
so this hindset relay link with with
gold States it actually works much
better and it can get to higher Rewards
or it can get there much faster
right I'm going to skip the image
observations but I wanted to tell you
one more thing so we can actually use
that insight for Better Learning and do
kind of reinforcement learning without
doing reinforcement learning at all
and to actually learn a little bit more
about this I encourage you to take a
look at this blog post or this paper
right here
so if any data is optimal because we can
always relabel it then can we just use
supervised imitation learning instead
and the truth is that you can so you can
collect data using any policy
then you can perform hindsight labeling
so in that case you know you'll take
that experience and just pretend that
the goal that you ended up in was the
goal that you wanted to to achieve in
the first place
and then store the relatable data and
update the policy Now using the
supervised imitation so you're just
doing imitation learning right so we
have the behavioral cloning case and
we'll be just conditioning on the goal
State and now since any trajectory can
be relabeled as an example of a
successful trajectory trying to get to
that goal that you actually got to we
can now the supervising mutation
learning on goal condition imitation
learning on any data set
and there is one example uh right here
where this is the work by Corey Lynch
and all
um called learning latent plans for play
where they collect some kind of data
where they ask humans to just play with
the environment
so they just record it using some kind
of cell operation tool they put some VR
headsets on people and ask them to just
you know do anything that you find
interesting in the environment so they
have the robot play with the with the
environment a little bit
and now they can use this unstructured
data relabel it using our goal condition
imitation learning and how they can set
any goal right so this is for instance a
goal image that they are trying to get
to and then the robot is trying to do
everything possible to get to that goal
so it tries to open the cabinet press
the right button and so on to get to the
goal so you can collect this kind of
unstructured demonstration data set
without any tasks anything in mind you
can relabel everything in hindsight
afterwards and then have this goal
condition policy work quite well
all right so we talked a little bit
about all four of these Banks the Q
learning multitasking mutation policy
gradients multitaskill learning goal
condition RL
there's a lot of remaining questions
that that will answer in the next few
weeks can we use a model what about met
RL what about exploration strategies and
what if we can't collect any new data uh
what about hierarchies of tasks as well
so we'll be talking about it in the in
the next set of classes
um additional few additional resources
if you're interested
um these are really useful thanks a lot
for coming and if there are any
questions I'm happy to take a note
thanks